[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
wednesday august 31st i'm zoe thomas for
the wall street journal
the national oceanic and atmospheric
administration or noaa is the government
organization that's tasked with
forecasting weather patterns
its predictions are used by the
government to prepare for heat waves or
storms and by outlets like the weather
channel and accuweather to report the
temperature to you and me
to get a lot of this information noaa
relies on satellites
and back in 2016 the agency decided to
turn to private companies to get more
satellite data more cheaply
but six years on despite a boom in the
number of private satellites in space
the government is still waiting for more
companies to jump into the weather data
market
joining us to discuss what's behind this
stall and how it's impacting the future
of weather forecasting is wsj pro's
enterprise technology reporter isabel
buscett
hi isabel thanks for being here yeah
thank you so much for having me
isabelle we hear so much about
satellites going up to space these days
so has the u.s government been able to
find that plethora of information that
it was hoping for
so the government has found two
companies to buy private weather data
from it started piloting these companies
kind of right off the bat in 2016 and
after four years of testing officially
started purchasing from them in 2020 but
beyond those two there really wasn't the
huge variety and plethora of data coming
out that they were sort of hoping for
and expecting i think what they found
and you know a lot of private companies
found is just that getting satellites
into space is
easier and cheaper than it's ever been
before but it's not that easy and it's
not that cheap it's still
incredibly difficult and takes a lot of
capital so it hasn't really materialized
in the way that they were hoping for
so what position does that leave the
government in i mean is there a way to
kind of get around this are they
encouraging more companies to to go up
what can they do i mean essentially what
they can do is just kind of sit and wait
for more private companies to enter the
market
it's a difficult situation because
essentially they can't
promise any companies that are in early
funding stages or any companies that
don't have satellites up there yet they
can't make any promises about data they
can or will purchase from those
companies those companies it's totally
up to them to get off the ground
if you will and get up into space and
start producing good data but if you're
a company that's getting a satellite
into space in order to produce weather
data there's not a lot of buyers for
that data outside of the government and
so without that government promise it's
sort of unclear
how much of a market there's going to be
for your data and so that's why venture
capital and other investors have been
kind of nervous to fund these
weather data collecting startups and so
that's kind of why noaa still just has
these two partners and they started
piloting a third this year and they are
optimistic it's just definitely been
slower than they were hoping okay so
let's talk about the data that they do
get from these private sector partners
how is it different or is it different
from the data that noaa was gathering
itself
yeah absolutely so it falls into the
same category as one type of data that
noaa was gathering itself so noaa
gathers a few different types of data
from satellites at all inform its
weather prediction models and one of
those key types is called radio
occultation
it's basically a fancy way of saying
that you can measure the disturbances in
radio waves and based on those
disturbances you can find out things
about
temperature and pressure in the
atmosphere so noaa's been doing that
forever and
now there are these two private
companies that are also doing that
the difference basically is that noaa
has a number of satellites out there
doing this they have one constellation
called cosmic 2 that does this but the
private companies are able to
essentially fill in gaps that aren't
covered by the satellites noaa covers so
noaa satellites tend to favor regions of
the earth that are closer to the equator
and data from the private companies kind
of spans the whole gamut like closer to
the polls and that type of thing so
they can definitely help fill in some of
those gaps and for that reason noah
thinks that that data is going to be
helpful to essentially creating more
accurate weather predictions the u.s
government works with private companies
all the time for things it buys
information from them it hires them to
help them build you know satellites or
roads plenty of other things so i wonder
if in this case though given that
there's so few partners if noah or if
congress sees this as a project that's
working out turning to the private
sector or if they have to recalculate
for my conversations with noah there's
definitely an optimistic bent congress
has definitely taken note of the fact
that noah has fewer private sector
partners than you know one would have
hoped at a certain point earlier down
the road and so they thought one problem
was that noah maybe wasn't soliciting
private companies often enough they were
doing it essentially every two years so
when they doled out noah's funding for
this earlier this year they recommended
that noaa seek out private companies
more often than that and noaa's now said
they're going to seek out private
companies at least once a year if not
more so
congress hasn't backtracked on the
project like they definitely still want
it to happen and they're still rolling
out funding for it and i think they're
just hoping that more entrants are going
to come into this market
so what happens next and i guess for you
know listeners who are thinking about
more severe weather patterns that we've
all been experiencing should we expect
that these forecasts will eventually
improve
yeah i think that's fair to say with the
amount of interest and innovation going
into weather data and the private sector
there's definitely a sense of urgency
and you know there is again enthusiasm
from the private sector this is a
problem that people definitely want to
solve but
there are definitely challenges and so
it has been slower but
the climate problem isn't going away the
need for better weather forecasts is not
going away so
there's no reason to think that there's
not going to be more capital and more
companies funneling into this space and
you know trying to solve this problem
better
all right that's our reporter isabel
busquet thanks for joining us isabel
yeah thank you so much for having me
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want more tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
and if you like our show please rate and
review it you can do that wherever you
get your podcasts i'm zoe thomas for the
wall street journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]